If then you have been raised with Christ, seek the things
that are above where Christ is
seated at the right hand of God.
Set your minds on things that are above,
not on things that are on earth
For you have died and your life is hidden
with Christ in God.
When Christ who is your life appears,
then you will also appear with him.
And,
Well, my name's John. I'm
one of the pastors of Henderson Hills.
And so if you're new, we're grateful
that you'd choose to be with us today.
We know it's not a small step
to take adventure into a new church family,
and so we are glad you're here.
I want to just acknowledge that and,
and ask for you to introduce yourself to us
so we can help you connect as best we can
towards those ends.
We're almost at the finish line in our semester long journey
through the Apostle Paul's letter to the Colossian Church.
And next week we'll be the end of it. So I'm dressing up.
I don't know if you are with me or not, that's up to you.
But, uh, we will enjoy the end of it.
But today we're just gonna be in five
verses of chapter four.
So turn there in God's word with me.
Colossians chapter four.
We'll be in verses two through six, just a few today
before we finish it out next Sunday.
Now it is a little bit different than Jake
and Elwood blues, their mission they were on,
but so you're gonna see today that just as much in some way,
we are also on a mission from God.
Uh, so that's where we're going today with this,
that passage as we see it.
Because the Christian faith is not merely intellectual.
There is a lot of head knowledge
and understanding of who God is and what he's done.
And that helps us then in our hearts grow to love him more
and to gratefully praise him more with, with a,
a true heart of worship.
But then it doesn't just stay there.
It's supposed to come into our hands, into our lives,
the way we live, the way we speak.
All of that is supposed to be changed by the faith
we call Christianity.
And Paul has set that up this whole time
through the letter to the Colossians.
He's talking to a church in a very dark city
where there's a lot of worldly powers
and philosophies around them.
There's a, a buffet of religious options
that they have in Colossae.
And he says, no wait. Christ is above all of those.
And he says it so clearly that Christ is the only way
to salvation that, that you don't need all
of these other religious practices on top of things.
You don't need any of that stuff.
You just need Christ as your substitute,
But in Christ saving you.
He's saying this to the Colossians as Christ has saved you,
he's made you new, that he's changing you from the
inside out to make you a completely different person.
That your life should now be a shining city on a hill
reflecting the change God's done in you.
Every facet of your life will be different.
And so today we're gonna see how we then they were
and we today are to carry that good news message to a lost
and dark world around us.
Similar to Colossae, how they were called to go take it
to people around them.
We the same are called to go on mission, to live sin
every day as well.
How do we do that? Well, Colossians four, two
through six will get us there.
Look at it now. Continue
steadfastly in prayer,
being watchful in it with thanksgiving.
At the same time, pray also for us that God may open
to us a door for the word to declare the mystery
of Christ on account of which I'm in prison,
that I may make it clear, which is how I ought to speak.
Walk in wisdom toward outsiders,
making the best use of the time.
Let your speech always be gracious, seasoned with salt so
that you may know how you ought to answer each person.
God, show us what you want us to see here in your word
and change us accordingly.
It's your work. Do it spirit in us. In Jesus' name. Amen.
Now he kind of does it here, but he'd already done this.
Paul had already commended the Colossians
for their faithful lifestyles back in chapters one and two.
He mentioned that a couple times the way they were living.
But but in the same vein, he had celebrated this good fruit
that God had produced in them
and through them, not only locally
but even to the ends of the earth, to the whole world.
He says, and he prayed that God would do that
through them even more.
That God's fruit would keep growing such
that it would keep spreading just from this little
church in Colossi.
Now what's the fruit he's talking about?
What's this spreading from Colossae?
What's the gospel truth being spread?
It's the disciples being made.
It's the same thing that Jesus ended with in Matthew 28 18
through 20, his ministry as he was about
to ascend to heaven.
He says this, the great commission, you might know it
as Jesus came and said to the disciples,
all authority in heaven on earth been given to me.
Go therefore and make disciples of all nations,
baptizing them in the name of the Father and of the Son
and of the Holy Spirit teaching them to observe
or obey all that I've commanded you.
And behold, I'm with you always to the end of the age.
And so that's the fruit He's saying.
It's spreading out from colossae to the ends of the earth.
And so just like he did back in chapter one for that kind
of fruit, he's saying he's praying for them
that fruit would expand.
Here he talks about prayer.
Again, Colossians four, verses two and three.
He talks about prayer.
The Colossians ought to pray steadfastly
and be thankful in their prayer for
what God has done for them.
But, but there's a little difference
what he did in chapter one.
Paul prayed for them that the fruit would grow through them.
Notice here in chapter four, he asks them to pray for him.
Really? He says, for us.
'cause remember all the way back in the first week we saw
that Timothy's there with Paul.
And so he's kind of writing this in conjunction.
So he says, pray for us. That's Timothy.
But notice Paul had no shame in asking them to pray for him.
He says, God, I need your prayers. Please pray for me.
What did he ask him to pray for though?
'cause he's in prison. He's like, Hey guys, can you pray
that God would miraculously break me outta prison?
Can you pray that God would make my life more
comfortable here?
Man, it's tough. No. What does he pray for?
He says, may you pray
that God would advance his mission through me.
He longed for them to pray for open doors for the gospel,
for this good news.
The go, the God's word would go forth.
He prayed that the gospel would spread even
among the prison guard, which we saw happen in Philippi,
that people even in the prison would be saved.
He said, that's what I want you to pray for.
That's why the first point today
is we're talking about God's mission.
It demands vigilant prayer.
It's not just that we can, all right, let's go live sin.
No, it demands vigilant prayer.
He asks them to pray for the mission.
In verse three, that open doors would happen to,
God's word would spread.
But verse two tells them how to go about that prayer.
Look again. Verse two.
He says, continue steadfastly in prayer,
being watchful in it with thanksgiving.
As you pray for the mission, that's how you're to do it.
Be persistent.
Be dedicated to practicing the discipline of prayer.
Now, this is not a new concept.
When you think back to the first disciples
after Jesus ascended, what did they naturally know to do?
Acts one. All they do to do is like just pray.
Jesus had ascended. We don't know what to do next.
So we just pray. They devoted themselves to it.
It says then in Acts two,
after the first church is formed, acts 2 42, it says,
that was part of what they did.
They devoted themselves to the apostles teaching
to the fellowship, to the breaking of bread
and to the prayers.
They were devoted to the prayers.
When you look at that verb in acts
or in Colossians four, two, continue steadfastly in prayer.
That is the same idea. Devotion to it, continuing in it.
And notice you might not be able to see it there.
It's a plural command meaning together.
So you could be devoted to prayer by yourself on your own.
This says, no, actually you should be the whole community
of faith devoted to prayer together.
'cause our faith is personal.
Yes, but it was never meant to be private.
God forms the body. He builds this family of faith.
It's never meant to be you and Jesus. That's it.
It's shared. It's a family.
Even this idea of prayer, he says,
continue steadfastly together in this.
That's why we,
we did this last year coming up in a couple weeks,
when the first week of 2024 happens, we're gonna do a week
of prayer to kind of devote the Lord, devote that year
to the Lord, and, and we're gonna plan a, a lot
of gatherings during that week where we can come together
to devote ourselves to prayer.
I'm expecting and anticipating you to do that
by yourself all year.
Of course, that's obviously part of our faith.
But, but in a unique way for us to come together
and continue steadfastly, devote ourselves to prayer
for the mission, for our church,
for each other, all of that.
Because it says, be watchful in prayer.
That word is to means to vigilantly. Keep your eyes open.
The idea is like a, a night watchman
or a a guard that is posted to spot the opposing army
or to watch and see for the bank robber
or for the iceberg that's coming ahead, right?
But, but the idea is to be watchful is
that you don't fall asleep on your watch.
I was thinking about this. I think it's the scene in every
movie where someone breaks outta prison,
where there's the guy kind
of slouched back in the chair, the guard, right?
And he's just sleeping about five feet
or so from the jail cell.
And somehow the prisoner finds a stick
and is able to maneuver that huge ring
that the key's sitting on, right?
And they're maneuvering in there
and they're just barely able to get it.
And then they break out that it seems like every movie,
maybe it's cartoons, that's all the movies I watch, but,
but maybe it's, that's how it works.
It's like that's falling asleep
and all of a sudden they lose the prisoner.
That's what we're seeing here.
God says, Colossians four,
we can't fall asleep on our watch in prayer.
We've got to stay vigilant to pray for ourselves of course,
but to pray for others, to pray for our church, to pray
for the mission of God, to go forth.
It has to be centered
and focused with prayer.
Remember the Colossians, they're in a tough spot.
They're a dangerous place. There's a lot of risk.
And so Paul says, pray. You have to pray.
Is that your go-to, are you
devoting yourself to prayer?
Are you disciplining yourself to go to war spiritually?
As Ephesians six says, this battle we're fighting,
it seems like it's a culture thing
or whatever, from an enemy outside.
No, the actual battle Ephesians six says is a spiritual one.
We're not battling flesh and blood. It's a spiritual battle.
So are you praying?
I'm, I'm so thankful for the many
prayer warriors we we have in this church.
I'm not still standing up here if we don't have them
praying, the ministry doesn't go forth like it does if
they're not praying for our church
because this is God's work.
We can be awesome and great and it doesn't work.
We can be normal. And it does work.
If God chooses to do whichever way he does, it's God's work.
And so when we pray, we're asking him to work
and we're asking him for the power to do
what he wants us to do in the mission.
God, we need you. We're just saying abide, right God,
this is your work.
When we abide, you produce the fruit. So we must pray.
Verse three. At the same time, pray also for us
that God may open to us a door for the word
to declare the mystery of Christ on account
of which I'm in prison, that I may make it clear, which is
how I ought to speak.
I've already mentioned this, but Paul mostly write,
most likely wrote this letter
to the Colossian church while he was in prison in Rome.
And he was in there not
because he was necessarily a criminal, it was
because he was a missionary of this mystery,
this gospel of Jesus Christ.
And they didn't like it. They thought he was subversive.
Now he's thrown in prison and somebody might think, well,
that's the end of his ministry, right?
No, Not at all.
Prison did not kill Paul's evangelistic activities.
In fact, it didn't even hinder it at all.
I mean, I love Paul, just think about this.
You couldn't do anything to get to Paul.
Like you say, Hey Paul, we're gonna kill you.
He's like to, to die his game.
But okay, well, well then we're we'll let you live.
We're gonna do this like, hey, to live is Christ alright?
We'll throw you in prison and you,
and okay, well I'll convert all your guards, right?
Like we're gonna go through this.
And he's like, you couldn't do anything to touch him.
Not only all that, not only was he propelled by this,
but him being put in prison actually encouraged other people
to share the gospel as well.
This is what he says in Philippians one, 12 through 14.
He says, I want you to know, brothers, that
what has happened to me has really served
to advance the gospel.
Me being thrown in prison has advanced the gospel.
How it has become known throughout the
entire imperial guard.
That's the kind of jailers you might think.
And to all the rest that my imprisonment is for Christ.
And most of the brothers having become confident in the Lord
by my imprisonment, are much more bold
to speak the word without fear.
So his pri, his imprisonment advanced the gospel.
And so here in Colossians,
Paul's saying, pray for the mission.
Pray that God would initiate it. God would assist it.
God would direct the avenues for me
to continue preaching the gospel.
Because his goal was to make clear,
or the other word might be reveal
this message from God about this Messiah
in Phil in Philippi, right?
The jail. He said, everybody had heard, I'm here
because of the Messiah here in Colossae.
When he is imprisoned in Rome, he's saying, man, I,
I want everybody to hear, I want everybody
to see about this Messiah.
I wanna reveal that.
By the way, it's the same word back in chapter three,
verse four, when he says, Christ will appear someday,
Christ is going to be revealed someday.
He's saying, I'm doing the same thing today
with this good news.
Like he's pulling the curtain back of this heavenly mystery
of salvation, something that's been hidden for generations.
He says, now it's been revealed in Jesus.
And he's exposing that, revealing it
to all these people who'd never heard it before
or had a Jewish perspective before.
Now he's like, Nope, here it is. It's in Christ.
And he was doing that no matter the cost.
And so the mission demands prayer.
But we also learn here
that God's mission demands bold revelation
of this gospel message.
It demands bold revelation.
Paul says, my whole goal, pray
for me the mission would expand so that I can reveal
boldly who this Messiah is.
Listen, you and I cannot be afraid of the consequences
of unveiling the mystery of this gospel
to a world that doesn't want to hear it.
And it might hurt a little bit.
It might mean that you lose friends.
It, It might mean you lose a job.
It might mean you go to prison.
It might mean you lose your life.
Now, I'm not saying we should be unwise
and just go about all this in a,
a really silly unwise kind of way.
But the reality is that all
of church history involves persecution.
We have been spared in many ways,
but all the rest of church history
involves persecution.
And I wrote that phrase
and I thought, okay, how?
How will I ever be prepared for that?
'cause you read stories and you hear of history like
how am I ever gonna be prepared for when not if, when
that time comes?
Well, a few weeks ago, one of our staff members, Kaylynn,
she shared uh, this story with me about Corey 10,
boom, you might know that name.
She's a Christian
who helped many Jews escape Nazi Germany in the forties
World War II time.
Here's what Corey said about preparing for persecution.
She said, when I was a little girl, I went to my father
and said, daddy, I'm afraid
that I will never be strong enough to be a martyr
for Jesus Christ, to be killed
for my faith, is what she's saying.
Tell me. I said, father, when you take a train trip
to Amsterdam, when do I give you the money for the ticket?
Three Weeks before, no daddy, you give me the money
for the ticket just before we get on the train.
That's right. My father said,
and so it is with God's strength.
Our Father in heaven knows when you will need the strength
to be a martyr for Jesus Christ.
And he will supply all you need just in time.
Very good. God's mission demands bold revelation
even when it costs us a lot.
He's worthy and he will provide the strength you need
to face whatever he's calling you to face.
And so the interesting thing about God's mission is it does
involve words, right?
We have a, it's called the good news after all right?
So the gospel is a message,
but the mission plays out in more than just speech
and words.
See, some people are called to be like Paul
and travel the world and share the gospel.
Some people are called to be like Billy Graham
and be a, a well-known evangelist to be able
to share the gospel anywhere and everywhere.
Some people are going to end up in prison
for the gospel, some won't.
But all of us are called to be
what Paul told the Colossians to be here in verses five
and six, whether those things are true of you
or not, this absolutely is true and should be true of you.
Verse five, walk in wisdom toward outsiders
making the best use of the time.
Let your speech always be gracious, seasoned with salt so
that you may know how you ought to answer each person.
Colossians, here's how you are to live. Same for us today.
That God's mission demands wise, conduct
God's mission, demands wise conduct as well.
Our lives are on display before the world.
They're a picture of what God does in someone
who believes of who he is.
So he talks about this walk. Well, that's our daily lives.
Remember he said that in chapter one,
walk in a manner worthy of the Lord.
Fully pleasing. Chapter two verse six, walk in him
as you've received him some parts of their lives.
Remember we said this last week about the household code.
Some parts of the Colossians lives would not look much
different from the outside as anybody else,
but in many ways they were not to fit in to the same way
of the Colossians around them.
Remember, husbands were not just to tolerate their wives.
Husbands were to agape love their wives.
Parents were to honor their children
and treat them with respect.
And, and masters were to honor slaves and,
and here he says not only all that they were also to walk
and live in a wise way.
They were to avoid sin,
but they were also to walk in a way
that would invite curiosity about their lives.
Like what is different about you?
It's what Philippians two 14 and 15 says.
He says, do all things without grumbling or disputing
or complaining that you may be blameless
and innocent children of God without blemish in the midst
of a crooked and twisted generation among whom you shine
as lights in the world.
It's the same kind of language Jesus used back in Matthew
five and the Sermon on the Mount,
it's probably coming from this.
It says, you are the light of the world.
A city set on a hill cannot be hidden,
nor do people light a lamp and put it under a basket,
but they put it on a stand
and it gives light to all in the house.
In the same way, let your light shine
before others so that they may see your good works
and give glory to your father who is in heaven.
Jesus tied your lifestyle to the mission,
the way you live to the mission.
The only way you can live that kind of life though,
like if you're gonna live a life that's good works
and above reproach and all of that, Colossians four, five,
you have to do that by making the best use of the time.
He says It's redeeming the time.
Buying it back is another way you could say it.
'cause here's the reality. Every one
of us has a limited amount of time on this earth.
If you live to be 80 years old,
you have 29,000 days to live your life.
And some of you that's like, that's forever 29,000. Okay?
29,000 days is really not
that many when you start to think about it.
700,000 hours.
This says, by the way, if Jesus comes back
before you died, do you have even less time?
Right? So this says to reclaim the time
to make the best use of the time is to make the most
of the opportunities you have for the gospel.
You can't do that once Jesus returns.
Once you go to heaven, like that's done.
The mission is accomplished at that point.
Until that time you have a limited amount of time.
And that's not just saying you need to read the Bible more
or you need to pray more.
Those are good things.
But notice what he says to do
to make the best use of the time.
Walk in wisdom toward outsiders.
You have a responsibility to obey Christ.
But that's not just an end in itself.
Notice it's actually for people
who are not yet believers too.
Walk in wisdom toward outsiders for those yet to believe.
It's walking the walk, not just talking the talk
that you are credibly showing
that something's happened in your life,
that Christ has changed you.
And I get it. I'm not,
you're not perfectly wise in all your conduct.
You're gonna fail. You're going to blow it.
But that's the beauty of the gospel.
See, even as you share about Jesus, you can talk about
how you need him just as much as they do.
Maybe the most powerful thing in your life is not
that everybody looks at you and says, boy, they're perfect.
That they look at you and say, man,
he knows he's not perfect.
And what they need to see is repentance.
And they see that you need Jesus
and you're clinging to his life,
death and resurrection in your place.
That's what they need to see, that you're walking the walk
as you repent.
So make the best use of the time.
One Corinthians six says, you're not your own.
You were bought with a price.
So you don't control this thing. This is not yours.
Plus you think Christ has come,
the kingdom has been announced, the new age has begun.
Christ has coming back soon to
to com completely consummate the kingdom.
All of this, these things are happening soon.
And so that's why we should not want to waste any time
that we've been given to Steward.
And so the question is, how do you want
to spend those 29,000 days?
How do you wanna spend those 700,000 hours
that you've been given?
Is that, is that meant to kind of create a pressure and a
and a weight on your shoulders?
No. But just think about how you wanna spend those time,
those days, those hours.
Is it watching cat videos on TikTok
fantasy football?
Is it endless scrolling on Facebook and Instagram?
Is it binging another TV show?
Is, is that making the best use of the time?
Walking in wisdom toward outsiders
or making the best use is getting involved in the mission
of God, living a life that points to him,
taking advantage of the opportunities he gives you every
single day with lost people.
That's at work, that's in your neighborhood,
that's at school, that's overseas,
that's in your neighborhood, all of that.
I've heard it said for years this way.
It was said many years ago, only one life
will soon be passed.
Only what's done for Christ will last
make the best use of the time.
Because here's the thing, you are going
to get opportunities.
If you look for opportunities. You just gotta look around.
You just gotta see who God puts in your path he's going
to get when you're looking for them.
So here's the question that we're gonna end with.
What do you do when you get an opportunity?
What do you say when you get that opportunity?
Look again at verse six.
Let your speech always be gracious, seasoned with salt so
that you may know how you ought to answer each person.
People are gonna ask you when you're living life empowered
by prayer for God's mission, asking him to speak
through you, walking wisely as Christ would.
People are gonna ask you, why do you do what you do?
And that's why God's mission also demands attractive speech.
That's what verse six just said.
It demands attractive speech.
Now I say that firstly, in general, the way
that you're supposed to to talk in your life
should be attractive.
It should not repel people in the way you just talk about
that it should be tasty to people.
You might say the way you speak,
that would've stood out in Colossae very much
'cause it was a harsh culture.
But the other way attractive speech shows up is
how you're able to answer those
who would ask you questions about your faith.
It's the same thing one Peter three 15
and 16 says In your heart's,
honor Christ, the Lord is holy.
Set apart, always being prepared to make a defense to anyone
who asks you for a reason, for the hope that is in you.
Yet do it with gentleness and respect.
Having a good conscience so that when you are slandered,
those who revile your good behavior in Christ may be
put to shame.
So notice, remember Paul, he was out in the streets.
He was in the synagogues,
he was traveling the world preaching the gospel.
That's what he was doing.
But you also see here, in a sense, there's a way
that we're inviting people in not just going to him
and proclaiming and kind of entering into their time, but
but inviting them into our lives such
that they hear the gospel as well.
That our individual lives, our families,
our church should be so attractive
that people want to be around us.
They want to know what we believe.
Why are you the way that you are?
And listen, Paul expected the believers in Colossae to do
that, in that kind of a culture as dark and lost
and pervasive as that culture was.
He still says you're gonna be able to live a life
that stands out, that people would ask you.
So we should be able to do the same kind
of thing in a culture like
Ours.
And so are we. Are
we living lives that are so attractive
that the world notices?
Would people all around us look at Christians
and look at churches and say, man,
there's something unexplainable going on over there.
Only some God could do.
What I see there is that happening.
Sadly, I don't think it is.
For the most part, I don't think we're living that kind
of a life for the most part.
I know I'm not
now, I'm not saying we're not part
of a lot of amazing things.
You look at orphan care, you look at widows, we're treating
with gentleness and kindness and provision
and disaster relief and pregnancy care and prison ministries
and all the things we, we see a lot of good.
But you know what else Christians are known for?
Snarky, disrespectful comments online,
deep division, a divorce rate
that's equal or above the rest of the world around us.
Gossip clicks at school,
rampant pornography use.
That's why when we speak about the gospel so often,
it falls flat because our our lives
are not credible that this has really worked.
Now God's gonna do his will with or without us.
He, he can accomplish this. He saves people.
Of course he will. And God absolutely uses broken
vessels like you and me.
But if we want to see him use us even more,
if we wanna participate even more with his mission,
then these verses today are critical.
We've got to pray vigilantly. We can't fall asleep.
We've gotta be ready, we've gotta be watching.
We've gotta be thankful. And we're praying
that God would do something
and we're trusting that he can and will.
We've gotta pray vigilantly.
We've gotta proclaim the gospel boldly when we get a chance,
not worried about the consequences,
but win some with our words, not intentionally provoking.
And we have to live holy lives
in the power of God's spirit within us.
We have to live a life that looks
like it reflects the new self that God's created in us.
We have to be different people.
That our words would echo the change
that God has made within us,
such that instead of unbelievers critiquing us,
hypocrites, you guys don't really believe what you say.
You don't look any different than us.
Instead of critiquing us, they would then instead say,
can you tell me more about what God has done in your life?
That's the hope.